what I like long and slow
for like you said the impact it has on
my cognition yeah it it uh the
wordlessness of it
um the way it puts you in in a the way
it seems to um clean out the Clutter
yeah you know um it can take away that
hyper focus and put you more in a
relaxed
Focus for sure well for me it brings the
Clutter to the surface at first like all
these thoughts come in there and then
they dissipate you know I've been uh
because I got knee barred pretty hard
that's when somebody tries to break your
nails yeah they try and break your knee
yeah because you tap so they yeah yeah
yeah so it's you know hyper extend they
need that direction the guy knee barred
pretty hard so um in ways I don't
understand it kind of hurts to run I
don't understand what's happening behind
there I need to investigate this
it basically this the hamstring Flex
like curling your leg hurts a little bit
okay and that results in this weird dull
but sometimes extremely sharp pain in
the back of the knee so I'm I'm working
I'm I'm working through this anyway but
walking doesn't hurt so I've been
playing around with walking recently
like for two hours and thinking I love
because I know a lot of like
smart people throughout history have
walked and thought and you have to like
you know play with things that have
worked for others not just to exercise
but to like integrate this very light
kind of prolonged exercise into a
productive life so they do all their
thinking while they walk it's like a
meditative type of walking it's it's
really interesting it really works yeah
the um the practice I've been doing a
lot more of lately as I walk while
reading a book in the yard I'll just
Pace back and forth or walk in a circle
audiobook are you talking no hard copy
where you just holding I holding the
book and I'm walking and I'm reading
yeah and I usually have a pen and I'm
underlining I have this whole system
like underlining Stars exclamation
points goes back to University of what
things that will go back to
um which things I export to notes and
that kind of thing
um but from the beginning when I opened
my lab at that time in San Diego before
I moved back to Stanford
um I would have meetings with my
students or postdocs by just walking in
the field behind the lab
um you know and I'd bring my Bulldog
Costello yeah Bulldog Mastiff at the
time and he was a slow Walker so these
were slow walks but I can think much
more clearly that way there's a Nobel
prize-winning uh professor at Columbia
University School of Medicine Richard
Axel who won the Nobel Prize co1 Nobel
Prize with Linda Buck for the discovery
of the molecular basis of olfaction and
um he walks in voice dictates his papers
and now with rev or these other maybe
there are better ones um than rev where
you can convert audio files into text
very quickly and then edit from there so
I I will often voice dictate
um first drafts and things like that and
um I totally agree on the long runs the
walks the integrating that with
cognitive work harder to do with sprints